parler de neymar la police brésilienne
réclament des poursuites contre
l'accusatrice du footballeur début juin
on apprenait qu'une jeune femme
brésilienne avait porté plainte dans un
commissariat de sao paulo à l'accusé
neymar de l'avoir forcée à avoir une
relation sexuelle dans un hôtel parisien
elles sont été d'ailleurs expliqué la
télévision brésilienne il ya quelques
mois et dans l'interview voilà la
plaignante avait déclaré qu'elle ne
déclenchaient pas cette polémique pour
de l'argent et la défense de neymar
voilà est la même depuis le 2 juin la
relation sexuelle a bien eu lieu mais
était parfaitement consentis et
aujourd'hui se passe linverse puisque la
justice demande des poursuites contre
eux la plaignante jean-michel avec elle
pour propos diffamatoires ce qui est
vrai qu'à parlement les prélats
l'enquète a été vite mené et tout porte
à croire que neymar n'a pas eu le
comportement qu'elle lui prêtait sert
d'autres l'avoir forcée à votre relation
tout était consentie même s'il a essayé
de faire croire le contraire et surtout
plus grave c'est que l'avocat de
l'avocat de le père de neymar neymar a
reçu un coup de téléphone de l'avocat de
la fille lui disant que moyennant argent
il pourrait avoir une entente et qu'il
n'irait ne porterait pas plainte donc du
coup d'attaqué pour extorsion de fonds
bâton de la part de la vallée de la
partie non mais je trouve ça très bien
c'est comme en france aussi ça devient
de plus en plus fréquents le procureur
de la république se retourner contre
vous pour faux témoignage à partir
moment vous saisissez la justice pour
moi je trouve ça très bien je trouve ça
terrible elle jette le soupçon sur son
avenir
on va dire alors qu' il ya des quarts
les agressions sexuelles ça existe oui
médiatique avec malgré tout jeter en
pâture
neymar en tant que footballeur
milliardaire forcément prédateurs
sexuels qui avait abusé d'une jeune
fille une pauvre victime
donc malgré tout se faire attention et
qu'on le veuille ou non serial fucker
ailleurs tout le monde n'est pas un one
shot in tout le monde à stein et donc
prédateur sexuel un serial fucker c'est
pas forcément un crime en fait on a
droit d'être un séducteur
on a le droit d'avoir plein de conquête
on n'est pas forcément dangereux et on
n'est pas forcément un agresseur
[Rires]
c
alors c'est pour lui jean listed à kelly
à isabelle ou à moi j'ai envie de toi tu
es bercy en danger tu es belle vous le
répéter américain non vous n'êtes pas
forcément voilà dangereux voilà non
juste sanaa ça n'arrivera je peux vous
dire ça n'arrivera pas voilà je vous le
dis non je sais pas si c'est un rêve ou
un cauchemar pour vous mais ça
n'arrivera pas voilà ça chez nous ou non
mais ça n'arrivera pas merci mr du plomb
dans la tête à lui merci à lui comparé
moment et pourquoi du comment arrêter
les super sympa à neymar break et l'a
contacté schalit sur un seul à jamais
s'il vous plaît on en est où avec neymar
kenny on est tout va bien rien n'a rien
est ce que vous êtes vus mais non est ce
que vous allez le voir non à